[Music]
yes
shut up
happy glorious wednesday it's day three
of our no in studio audience so if you
don't hear any laughter following many
of my brilliant jokes just pretend
you're watching joy behar do stand up
i feel like that last cnn producer in a
healthy sexual relationship
so alone
case in point just now
now remember the maniac who was freed
without bail after he torched the fox
news christmas tree last month no not
chris cuomo
this guy craig tamana nana i know this
is going to blow your mind but he's on
the lamb and not in a good way you
animal lovers yeah he actually escaped
from not being in prison
which i know seems kind of pointless
but he failed to comply with the
conditions of his release according to
the manhattan da's office an office that
lets more criminals off than greyhound
he was arraigned on one count each of
felony second-degree criminal mischief
misdemeanor second degree reckless
endangerment and misdemeanor 5th degree
arson yeah who knew torching a 50-foot
tree on a crowded sidewalk is considered
mischief
and here i stopped at tp in the high
school gym
just last year but due to criminal
justice reforms enacted in 2020 no bail
was set so even though the judge ordered
the guy to regularly check in with the
supervised release program he didn't
so now he's missing like petty cash when
cat's around
so yeah he didn't check in surprising
right next you're probably going to tell
me william devane buys gold
or miley cyrus has a tongue
credit to billy ray i never thought you
could create something more annoying
than achy breaky heart
but you did but who could have seen this
coming this whole issue has to do with
the revolving door of justice the guy
that lift the tree on fire is probably
going to get out today or tomorrow
because
not a felony arson what he did it's an
offense under new york law where he has
to be bailed so he's going to be out he
might be out right now yeah
so good looking but hey mr magoo could
see this coming if he hasn't already
been shot
so the libs seeing the errors of their
ways nope instead of reversing their
destructive pro-crime practices that
have led to insane surges of violence
they're tripling down on their stupidity
and even though we've heard great
stories about our new tough on crime nyc
mayor his new progressive d.a alvin
bragg won't seek prison for most crimes
downgrading felony charges and armed
robberies so one elected d.a now has
more power over laws than all three
branches of government he's going to
support police like a water bed
you remember those jimmy
this after smash and grabs are more
common in stores than nipple-less
mannequins
they make no sense yes bragg has ordered
prosecutors to stop seeking a carceral
sentence for anything short of murder or
deadly assault carceral being the cool
new word for people who think joy reid
is deep
also he says minor crime won't be
prosecuted at all so unless you're
dismembering a family with a bolo knife
on their front lawn at noon you're not
going to be inconvenienced with jail
time and forget about the quality of
life law enforcement that cleaned up new
york decades ago
now anything goes these sidewalks are
going to be covered in more poop than a
german porn star after the director
yells cut
you know what i'm talking about cat
sure crime will drop because there's no
point to reporting it
some examples from bragg's memo include
armed robbers who use guns or other
deadly weapons to stick up stores and
other businesses will be prosecuted only
for petty larceny a misdemeanor well i
wouldn't want to be a cashier right now
their lives don't matter
convicted criminals caught with weapons
other than guns
will have those felony charges
downgraded to misdemeanors so what
weapon could they be talking about
sporks
burglars who steal from residential
storage areas will be prosecuted for a
low level class d felony and you know
what that means a dramatic increase in
booby traps
and of course instead of calling brag
out for this insanity the media will
probably lap it right up
tonight on the chess news network
[Music]
david rooks for the chess news network
we're outside manhattan's courthouse
where the revolving door of justice is
spinning like a lathe here's a recently
reformed citizen now sir sir please
don't hurt me sir sir is this your wife
this chick no we just met us a court
stenographer
uh well how does it feel to be free oh
it feels absolutely amazing to know that
i'm no longer a threat to society or
those six people i stabbed
so you've learned your lesson oh
absolutely it's goodbye guns and knives
hello to bats and honey showing that new
stuff we got
a box of dynamite
fresh can of poison so we're gonna have
a great time and now if i get locked up
no one's gonna think i'm a [ __ ] well
these don't sound like anything that
could result in felony charges to me
what's next you know i think i'm gonna
enjoy the fresh air before i fill it all
with burning smoke see in hell let's go
living hell indeed and just like caviar
at a martha's vineyard birthday party
justice has been served back to you fred
now if you're not living in new york
city you're probably thinking yeah
typical stupid libs it's on you for
living there you should move the hell
out or shut up
first of all don't ever tell me to shut
up
imaginary person and second it's no
longer new york city it's america and by
america i mean texas and by texas i mean
mexico
according to victim advocate groups
criminal suspects released on multiple
felony bonds in texas most populous
county
have murdered 156 people since 2018.
yeah over 150 people have been killed by
free-range scum all murders that could
have been prevented again this is texas
where kids have gun racks on their big
wheels
that's not new york or california or
seattle or portland it's texas the red
state the law and order state the last
hope we have the joe manchin of states
and yet they have to just keep taking it
like they're being hazed into a frat
i wonder what the angry black male
thinks
what's wrong with my radio
got felt
hello gutfeld
and you know what
i am angry and you should be angry too
everyone should be angry
right now in certain states a man could
get up in the morning
go to a building burn down a christmas
tree
that could have hurt thousands of people
maybe worse and then be out in time to
get marshmallows to toast his
marshmallows over the smoldering flames
of what's left of his work that's where
we're at that's what's going on
so we should be pissed off we should be
upset
armed robbery
for victims is some of the worst things
they can go through a gun to your face
your belongings taking your humanity and
digging taken away from you and now it's
a misdemeanor
what are we doing
they run the dinner bell
and we need to be prepared
and i'm angry
he's right so unless we start our own
anti-crime movement and recall these das
and then do these laws we're screwed
and think about that tomorrow as other
networks will wax horrific about the
so-called insurrection
turns out the only criminals who matter
to the media are goofballs and viking
hats meaning they'll condemn anything
that validates their disdain for you as
it places them the media in the dramatic
center of a mostly peaceful protest that
left an unarmed woman dead but who cares
about her right remember it's just like
those riots of last year crime doesn't
happen if the media doesn't think it's a
crime and it's never a crime if it
doesn't happen to them
let's welcome tonight's guest our wild
audience goes crazy
his personality's electric and so is
bikes ceo of electric bike technologies
jason kraft
the buck stops here that's what people
tell him when he tries to crash their
party radio and podcast host buck sexton
well the 70s called and they don't want
his wardrobe back box across america
host jimmy fella
and finally she drinks champagne from a
shoe to avoid washing dishes foxy's
contributor cat tim
once again jimmy you've outdone yourself
with your wardrobe you look like a
sad groom on a vegas wedding cake
i was going like saturday night fever
but you can't say that now you'd have to
stay home because you had a fever yeah i
think it's my first spotted fever yeah
you're like the court jester of the
medellin cartel look at it nice to have
you back yeah it's pretty tight though
you've been working out or did you just
eat another version of you no i'm
pumping uh i actually like the shoes and
the socks do they come in men
i love you so jimmy you are a uh you're
a you're a you were a cab driver you
know you've been you know you know what
it's like i assumed to be mugged oh yeah
like people jumping out in the fair and
stuff like that but i just want to say
this really quick yeah you're driving a
cab full-time people always ask do you
profile when you're driving a cab do you
ever not pick somebody up who looks
dangerous but the truth is if you're
driving a cab 12 hours a day you want to
die yeah
so like honestly if there's anybody
watching at home if i didn't pick you up
it's because you didn't look dangerous
enough you know what i'm saying yeah a
little bit harder but but knowing how
primal the situation is on the street
here and these da's and the people
passing these laws and these bail
reforms aren't necessarily living in the
reality they've created they're really
doing something terrible because i you
know a lot of people have the luxury of
not knowing how raw and rugged the
streets get and how difficult police
work is and this idea that we've created
an environment that's more empathetic
for the criminal than the victim is why
we are where we are where if you go to
times square remember those famous
walking tours of the architecture right
they're now called running tours because
you're going to get chased it's a bad
situation but that's why this d.a brag
is just a woke pandering jackass and the
hope here is this is the real litmus
test for eric adams who's the new mayor
who does in some capacity have to clear
this right the hope is that adams has
some balls because they shouldn't go on
oh if he if he doesn't reject this stuff
and he's he's worse than de blasio i was
going to say he's just de blasio he just
took the baton the one thing i would
point out about texas really quick is um
that largest county is houston and
houston to some extent is not the rest
of texas it's true it's like austin with
showers yeah you know i was uh you know
i was hoping you wouldn't point that out
because that was the hole in my
monologue
was that you can't really say houston's
texas but thanks for that jimmy well
that's what you get for gunning down my
wardrobe again hello
so jason you once you lived in a city
but now you moved out of a city
people came to the city because you were
allowed to commune safely that was the
whole point you could be around people
but you could be protected once you
remove that what is the point to living
in a city i don't know i don't like
coming here at all
honestly i come here maybe twice a year
i come here for christmas yes i'm here
for the christmas stuff with my kids i
have three young kids yeah and my wife
brings me here in july for her birthday
those are the only two times and it's
dreadful both times even on her birthday
i eat it's so bad
it's so bad if you know when i come with
the kids in the in the whole family it's
i'm like watching the president
yeah like my head is on a swivel yeah
waiting for something to happen i can't
stand it and the whole place now that
pot's legal yeah the whole place smells
like food trucks right uh weed and pee
okay yes in that order thank you you
leave cat's apartment yeah
but you know look i don't know what's
going on with these politicians i mean
they basically give the criminals a
blueprint here yeah which is crazy
you're telling them in advance you know
what they can get away with and they're
just going to go and do it and i in that
story you got to listen to the cops i
mean nobody listens to the people who
are yeah and they're saying they don't
even want to arrest these people yeah
because they know they'll be out why
right now like what's the point yeah you
just pissed about so it's all messed up
and i think you're right i think this uh
this new guy adams got in on all these
promises and it's complete 180 so yeah i
don't know what's going on how's i don't
know how this happens but it's your
problem i'm going back to new hope after
that yes going back to p.a
buck uh why is why did this happen and
why does it keep happening
well one thing is that it's become
fashionable for democrats now to take
this position that criminals should be
coddled and that society's all
responsible for it i grew up with comic
books i remember in batman arkham asylum
and they would let it loose and then
everyone was there seems to be a program
here in mind of ending they'll talk
about the carceral state which by the
way is like cisgender or it's a term
it's undocumented it is a term that
tells you everything you have to know
right away someone says that the
carceral state
but they actually want to end mass
incarceration that's the overall
movement what they mean by that is empty
out prisons it's not that everyone in
prison is not guilty so it's like the
parts of the comic books where they're
emptying out arkham asylum so to speak
in batman and letting everyone run free
and see what happens in the city and
until you have drive-bys in nantucket
they're going to be a lot of people who
and this has happened i know people like
this we're saying new york's not that
bad i'm like aren't you in palm beach
about six months of the year or aren't
you in martha's vineyard or you know
wherever or the hamptons or the hamptons
is probably the biggest one for new
yorkers so for them they get to be
fashionably concerned with the poor
while more people are getting stuff
stolen from them and shot while
democrats tell them this is because
we're a bad country we have to suffer
for our sins that's why it's happening
and until we suffer more they're going
to keep doing it until it happens to
somebody in the media and then all of a
sudden that's why january 6 is such a
big deal to them because they were there
and they suffered ptsd from it so it's
like to them that's the actual crime not
the thousands of murder victims in the
united states cats
you know cat you have been a proponent
of police reform this kind of ruins it
ruins your uh wholesome
principles by attaching it to the
release of unwholesome criminals do you
see my point i see i i hear your red
meat talking point but i i disagree
because some of the stuff like drug
dealers like drug dealing is just two
adults consenting i agree you know but
the armed robbery thing for example i
think that if you point a gun at me and
take my stuff like you should go to jail
but that it's also like the most
pro-second amendment thing that
manhattan's ever done that is so true
like yeah the armed robbery is okay like
at least criminals are allowed to have
guns they'll make sure that the people
who should i'm not allowed to have guns
but if you want to have one legally you
have to i can't have a gun unless i'm
going to rob somebody and if somebody
tries to defend themselves with a gun
then they're they are screwed right and
i go you it brings me to the point that
a side i made in my monologue the booby
trap if they're saying that people can
break into your
and you can't do anything about it
they're going to be like people just
setting up
i can assure you having worked the mypd
for a little while that in the city
right now if you had an armed robbery to
catch situation going on a guy points a
gun at her she pulls her
illegal weapon and shoots the guy she's
going to go to prison for under the new
guidelines the violence with the firearm
the armed robber guy i don't know maybe
he gets to she's not going to last i was
guessing i would not do well in prison
yeah yeah yeah
who's going to put herself in storage
anymore yeah that's true
well the storage companies are going to
have to then
uh ramp up their security and or else
they're they're going to go out of
business it's like a christmas stuff did
you know that by the way since we have
the electric uh electric bicycle expert
here so my electric scooter got stolen
on the show so the crime wave became
very real to me this is right during the
holidays by the way and i've been told
i've been told that there are just i
said how did this even happen it was
right outside the restaurant and it was
locked up the thing was you know broken
they they took it away and someone told
me that there are just trucks that they
they have basically now like moving
trucks they go around the city and
they're just stealing all the electric
bikes and scooters they can because
they're like what's going to happen
really yeah with that you know you know
[Laughter]
is there anything sadder though than a
guy named buck sexton driving an
electricity
everybody's thinking harley chopper this
is like my name is tex colorado and i'm
a vegan you know all right i love you
man we got to move on hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else